if you're asking me what can an
e-commerce business learn from be
friends and be gone the answer is brand
over everything brand is the ultimate
way to sell
trade attention and build businesses
we are wrapping up here in Brisbane very
successful three City Tour lots of good
content lots of great memories
[Music]
we're at the place where in the middle
of Brisbane I can get a Gary someone
brand is being built
[Music]
once in a blue moon out of nowhere I'll
give insight to why I created a
character one of my favorite things
about me friends I wanted to create
characters that are ironic to belief
systems today that's why the black cat
is the logo the very very very very
lucky black hat that's like in complete
contrast to black cats being unlucky the
reason I created self-aware hair the
process of living life to become more
self-aware to then be able to live
comfortably within yourself and accept
yourself is funny because the hair loses
to the tortoise so here's the fast one
the tortoise eats the hair and that's
why I created self-aware hair
[Music]
oh it's been so far in Australia I'm
very excited today
I've been in Melbourne Sydney and now
Brisbane all the last 48 hours
[Music]
how do you tell the difference between
like someone just having a bad day
versus someone that's genuinely just not
a good person sustained
default into it's just a bad day when
they sustain it for a long period of
time then I'm able to say this is really
a small cinch and I genuinely don't
think anyone's bad I think everyone
's bad is the pain and there's a way to
fix it so then I guess first impressions
is not really a thing for you nope first
impressions are a thing for me jumping
to conclusions and deciding
deciding off of a singular impression is
one of the most intellectually
emotionally lazy activities a human can
do and it is now a global pandemicism
[Music]
we got it
we're just kids in the neighborhood
[Music]
hello hello hello hello
how are you gang good to see you do you
think platforms about Rocco on Twitter
present obviously sense or anything do
you think they'll stop growing and
overtaking the others or do you open no
I don't feel overtake I think you'll
have options and what gets censored
changes over time too my career I could
never be a big speaker in 2009 because I
curse too much and that I dress too
casual and I left a lot of money on the
table are you gonna change or are you
just gonna be patient you know and
that's becomes the game you could also
do what you're doing content-wise you
could make content that is beeping out
or slightly more edited and social but
then provide them to your environment
and be what as crazy as [__] you want
to be
as you should so don't be philosophical
or emotional about it double down on the
truth one of the biggest strengths I
have is I leave my feelings at the door
when I do business every minute that you
two say [__] you know meta or Instagram
or Tick Tock is a second that you're not
putting into creativity to drive people
to go to your website so
thank you everyone
just leave them stick it to him
[Applause]
thank you
how many people here are doing social
media content for themselves or business
or something of that nature raise your
hands raise them high I want to get a
sense if you are not doing Facebook
reels you're missing a huge opportunity
so Facebook reels is huge organic
similar to tick tock 40 years ago I
think LinkedIn is wildly underused you
know people think LinkedIn is B2B
business if you're selling frisbees you
should be posting on LinkedIn those two
are the underpriced attention then it
becomes a game of best one of my
favorite other excuses Ethan is like
people dming me like Gary I need your
help I'm Shadow banned then I click
their account and look at their content
I'm like ah got it go back to the DM hey
brother you're not Shadow band you just
suck
everybody here wants to blame the
algorithm I'm not getting as much reach
on my Facebook on my Instagram they just
want ads they want the money no no the
reach was free like you post and people
see it and they don't charge you I'm
just gonna say this nice and slow
Instagram's free do you know how insane
that is go try to call the newspaper of
this [__] town and ask them to put an
ad in the paper for free go run a
commercial on seven for free go get a
billboard on these nice little streets
out there for free it's [__] free if
it's free and everyone's there then it
becomes competitive and instead of
crying about the algorithm or all these
other people how about getting better at
it and better at it means knowing how to
title your videos what the thumbnail
needs to look like what the first three
seconds should look like the copy that
you support it with what time you post
it and what about putting in the hours
of reading and testing and working to be
good at it you guys ready for questions
hold on that was such [__] are you
guys ready for questions
so I experienced vegan at the start of
econ you talked around Journey that you
see where to go on from strangers to
acquaintances to friends or family yeah
and that was for me the epitome of econ
I run a small agency work on the Shopify
with all the wins that you've had
through V friends and all the care
liberations what do you think that
e-commerce businesses can take from your
learnings within building this community
that are empowered to grow the brand
themselves you know vehicle has moved
Beyond you beyond just your characters
what do you think e-commerce businesses
I mean that brand is the ultimate way to
sell the reason most people that Focus
just on math and ads don't build the
biggest things in the world is because
the art and the communication and the
emotion always outflanks the math you
need the math math is massively
important obsessed with ads but if
you're asking me what can an e-commerce
business learn from be friends and V con
the answer is brand over everything and
brand means storytelling and good intent
and content with no expectation of a
transaction in return on that day
thank you
good stuff I like that format a lot I
can do it all day I love that sweater
yeah what's your name I'm Charlie
Charlie such a pleasure hi I hope you
enjoyed today I did I'm 17. I don't know
what I'm doing fine no 17 year old does
not one and the ones that think they do
are going to change their mind along the
way you've got time thank you you're
welcome
right
thank you very much of course thank you
team thank you so much
I started my own brand and it's done
really well and I wanted to give you
this I love it put it on I would love to
bye everyone have a wonderful weekend so
nice meeting you so nice seeing all of
you I already miss all of you
I'm [__] tired about to walk in see
some be friends
[Music]
I'm Blown Away about the concept of
strangers becoming acquaintances tonight
many strangers are going to become
acquaintances and then acquaintances
become friends and then friends become
family it's very real the byproduct of
this Mission the thought that it's going
to lead to fruitful relationships means
a lot to me I'm gonna walk out of here
and feel very blessed and so please I
encourage you to get to know each other
I love you guys thank you thank you
we are wrapping up here headed to the
airport in Brisbane very successful
three City Tour lots of good content
lots of great memories my friends with
my new friends my acquaintances
it's a good [__] show I'm pumped
foreign
[Music]